yes sir how was Calgary oh you know yeah
June Canadians dude - maybe he'll go did
you go to gravity poke get yourself some
shoes like I told you no not grab a I
want this place called Lex on the
average some [ __ ] like that
you want my style did you have the
Chinese that's nice there yeah and then
over to analog coffee yeah
I'm go there every time I hang a shack
up there so our boy Chris Chris labelled
a good man that fort a beast uh-huh you
know Calgary bro a Calgary Calgary you
know they the Calgary and Denver similar
that built around the same time and they
they kind of mimic each other so there's
a lot of similarities to Denver now
agree same designers I guess love that
really architect yeah huh strange right
yeah that that area man you go if you
just step out of Calgary and get into
those oil fields it's a desolate part of
the world like Edmonton that there's
some cool like where they call it Banff
oh it's beautiful yeah yeah I think
there's some Grizzlies up there now you
want to be careful how about your friend
your boy crazy Chris will run at 5:00 in
the morning she's all else not doing
that
no not too yeah I think Grizzlies up
well if Chris keeps that angry face he
had on your Instagram tell you that he
runs with that face space although I
heard grizzly bears don't like Botox
they should be alright well okay then I
don't know maybe it maybe it's it
doesn't taste like beer your face helmet
if you have Botox I didn't know he was
doing Botox but if he is is that the
rumor III never confirm it yep alright
well Chris is very open about everything
so I don't think about on stage oh he
does yeah Chris oh stop it right now or
like a hand you or not it's good
good-looking kid forty something um he
runs at five in the morning I'm not
doing that
I'm just not doing that because what
happens is a bear the winds blowing the
other way and the bear is talking he's
alright and then you run up on him and
he's like what the [ __ ] well that's one
beer are they like sharks dusk and dawn
you don't run at dusk you don't run at
dawn there's that terrifying video of
that guy on a mountain bike and he's on
a GoPro and he looks back in that bear
is chasing have you seen that that blurs
oh my god yeah bear chases got seen the
mountain lion that's falling the home
boy around
well that's not bears are much worse I
don't mind the Grizzly yeah I mean a
grizzly like the Grizzly there's gogoro
yeah watch this well we get kicked off
chin I'll just watch this where is he at
where's he at Calgary yeah just watch
buddy oh damn he was quiet he just went
oh God okay this guy's the worst in bed
that looks so fake
it's not though god I'm not sure I'm
buying it
it looks pretty fair it's not no sound
the beard doesn't go in that guy's right
I guess still coming after him yeah
digitally come on
nothing is chasing right yeah oh this is
fake is oh this is real I'm just because
you're here Cooper fake I tell you my
mother said that to me I go I'm losing
my hair my mother let's just get a week
now see that's dangerous what's the fake
video on watch it it's all fake doesn't
mean that's fake do they got cowan they
get the come on I'll go back what that's
so fake yeah it's super big it is yeah
yeah all right don't were 50 dude I'd be
so [ __ ] afraid dude all right are you
sure looks too colorful oh you know you
might be right
oh the Bears the only clear thing in the
video Brian hey hold on yet noms I'm
sitting here with him now yeah you know
what 2019 I appreciate your ass right
here yeah I don't know okay yeah I know
it's so annoying yeah thank you okay
bye-bye bye-bye let's do a 19 technology
here Matt yeah ah man dude I was a long
range shut the [ __ ] I was afraid
god but it happens voila video though
you know well when you're wearing cope
that guy we're like this all right here
comes in rest here in real life all I
know what all right
oh that's super fake yeah
get that [ __ ] on my face channel now
dude my favorite is now baguette that's
the first signal you don't want to run
that in five in the morning go dude
but I don't know man you know I mean
what do you see home well no about she
was at swimming at dust swim the mill
the day in Hawaii and she yet you see
she lost
oh no they saved both her arms she lost
her leg teenage girl she was like she
got ginger I like an emo girl and then
her dad it's so funny it's not funny but
it's so her dad is a TMT or like this
firefighter starts punching the shark
and had to lift her out of the water
while the shark was attached to her and
so there it's like they're on Dateline
the time about how heroic is and then
the girl you tell the girl to have the
best relationship with her dad she goes
and then my dad was like I can't do this
I can't you know we gonna try to make
the dad look great like can't before
when the water start pushing the shark
lift your girl out and then go the Donna
she goes yeah when my dad's pull me out
he kept saying I can't do this I can't
do this thing let me go and then finally
the shark you didn't tell her I was like
hey man like through the data of the
table a little bit more girl but the dad
was exhausted oh he must have been
exhausted
well I ever told you the time I tried to
break my dogs off I was on a date in my
house they were fighting in my front
yard and I was trying to get my pitbull
and my German Shepherd off each other
and every time I would choke one out the
other one would grab the other one I've
choked him out I went I told you I was
trying to pull him off of my hands he
was my hands and those are two 45 50
pound dogs now imagine if now imagine if
someone had your kid a shark the mount
well I told you that serial killer it's
a dark story is a dark story but the
serial killer that book I'm reading
right sitting across table from the
killer
the circular they said what kind of high
would you get when you murdered people
he says it strongly it's so high that
when he wanted to hide the body of this
girl that he killed he saw a Volkswagen
an old beetle he's a big dude but lifted
it put the body on and then lift it back
down he goes my drone was pumping so I I
had the endorphins the [ __ ] left that
car when there what's your eyes so
he got caught and the police or I did
where's the girl he's like under that
Volkswagen busted like how the [ __ ] did
you what machine did you use he's like I
did it I was I was on so much adrenaline
I left that thing myself it took two
machines and eight men to left that
[ __ ] thing I find that girl goddamn
crazy right yeah
Ellen it's a pump it it's weird feats of
strength like you can get but that's
super dark to the serie killa butyl I'm
saying so Robert Sapolsky is that
behavioral psychologist who studies like
he wrote a book called behave which is
like tracing when you make a decision
like the decision you make might have
started the chain reaction may have
started like a month ago or something
you know it's like the studying that
kind of a neural chemistry of
decision-making and and he said that we
will probably look at this this kind of
behavior and study why people get this
[ __ ] like little orphan that end go
oh that's just the way his brain is
wired and he has no control over there's
no serial killers I'm talking mark yeah
like where where that kind of think
about that kind of rush you get cetera
if you can lift a car up a [ __ ]
minivan well obviously you might be
completely at the mercy of this insane
impulse and so what do you do while you
kill them are you yeah he fixed our
brain ordeal she got taken by did raises
a question where you're like oh you
can't help yourself oh you you actually
can't help yourself
this is a compulsion that goes so far
beyond what you're able to deal with
yeah and some people might get it you
know through certain you know some
people get that adrenaline rush if they
fight octagon or head box or ASCII or
yeah you got a [ __ ] hot girls what
care a sucky high wait a minute he was a
wheelchair and I he took pictures in
Tempe Arizona and good-looking kid and
he was always ten feet by the way it was
I don't maybe it was uh people it's
[ __ ] same as Phoenix
like cool spot like Phoenix yeah but I
actually prefer it oh yeah yeah I think
you've never done Tampa never done do
Phoenix and a blonde because the
original club Bob so Tempe was is it
because I don't know no attempt it's an
improv Oh Tempe is one of the older
clubs so Tempe goes way back so the
acoustics the way it's set up is not
corporate ooh that's cool
it's 450 people I've sold more tickets
there this weekend than I rather I think
that was great but it's you'll love that
oh I'm sorry too happy you'll love it
sounds cool yeah everything about it I
will nuts don't live Justin yeah just
tell him I was great too but they have a
new club there they're opening another
club in North Phoenix where it's gonna
be a soundproof wall but I didn't give
you a dog whetted Tempe you can get my
dry beak in there okay it's back this
burning will happen a homeboy in a
wheelchair
so he was a motocross guy and he just
was it was a maniac and that's what he
got got off on and just got [ __ ] up
and injured paralyzed or no just like he
said dude I had some gecko my show in
Calgary young strapping lad big dude 6-4
240 got a car accident [ __ ] him up so
bad he's like I know I mean you know if
time I know exactly
he comes every show really nice guy
good-looking kid too tall yeah but a
mess but you could tell just a be so an
athlete gonna got rear-ended and just
[ __ ] him up so he shakes yeah and his
speech is slurred and yeah really nice
guy but you know the it's not the
security is like you got to move them
wanna keep talking like chill dude the
kids went through some [ __ ] I'm glad you
talked to him yeah really nice guys III
I almost started crying I almost started
crying when there was a kid in my front
row with his mom and he had a cane and
he was blind and temping he was laughing
his ass off and then he came up to me
and said 23 and he lost his sight at 19
his mother and he said you your podcast
stopped me from killing myself Jesus
Christ said you guys stop me from
killing mice did he say did he say
listen I listen to bryan callen show I
want to kill myself
my kid saved my life no that's not what
he said no that's what he said that's
know how what do you say when you're on
your own
I thought about slit my wrists and why
now let's just show I thought this they
ever hurt that's not what he thought
let's define kidding no no that's not no
sure no that's not what he said you
can't no credit Connie no I feel like I
feel like you're using his loss of slang
you're welcome nope you're welcome blind
I feel like you're losing it using his
loss of sight to justify my insult it's
not cool
no that's not cool I don't think it's
cool to him but he said to me 19 years
old
hee hee as a condition it's hereditary
laughs well he lost his sight his nerves
died in his eyes and his mother looked
at me and said yeah he was gonna kill
himself but your PI stuff said said you
keep in touch their pudding so I don't
know if you listen to the Rogen thing
with David Sinclair where they are
they're reversing a blindness and mice
crushed the optic nerve yep they're
doing it with viruses he's on a trial
he's in a trial phase where they shot a
virus in his [ __ ] eye hopefully it
[ __ ] yes yes I'm trying to do the same
[ __ ] they do with mice with his eye they
will do this they will in in the next 10
years they are going to have hope you'll
see again I told him that I said we
watched to some dude you gonna be able
to see it okay but don't do it he's
giving you a thumbs up I hope he's
listening wish I knew the kid's name
giving you a thumbs up and holding it
you can't see that I know buddy well
he's back in look alright there's no
doubt there's no doubt he'll get his
[ __ ] yeah man that's cool yeah have you
ever seen the videos though those that
make make make me cry a kid here in uh
for the first time name for the first
time start crying they put the thing
like and then they're like let's see if
it works it'll be like Joshua and he's
like like oh [ __ ] the kid starts crying
yeah oh man how about my my daughter is
taking voice lessons now and she's
learning how to sing stage dad for me I
was just sitting there and my
father-in-law one of my favorite people
in the world he's next to me and she
starts to sing and he starts to cry oh
that I get you I was like yes yeah what
is it about I I don't cry but there are
a couple things that make me cry when I
see a soldier come back and surprise his
kids because you're Hugh I cry I think
everybody cries it well when I say
something I wanna go what about when
people sing when I live it's good enough
all straight especially when they look a
certain way or that autistic kid
or if they if they look like [ __ ] I sing
like an angel they look like [ __ ]
[ __ ] one day man dude I'll get one
here me too me too
and and how
this job went you know what give me in
the back of the line for look yeah front
of the line for seeing it how about this
my seven-year-old son my seven-year-old
niece I play that autistic kid from
America's Got Talent
singing manie's starts to cry she's so
overwhelmed she gets it my son can't
deal with these emotions no he can't
deal with the emotions just like his dad
he goes I'm not gonna watch this I think
there's a lot that goes into it
nobody was moved I think he just had
yeah yeah but I'll set seven like what
seven he's like whatever no certain
thing well today I went to Toy Story for
us they took my son and my girl they can
make a movie that was all right it's a
little drawn-out but they can't make a
movie but then set everyone this is a
spoiler
everyone knows even Tom Hanks said he
start crying shooting the movie so in
the theater I mean there was like
straight-up parents crying kids not
really kids like what the [ __ ] you gonna
be fine but do you think parents are
straight-up crying did you ever have a
movie do you guys ever have a movie one
movie that changed the way you lived
your life to where you saw a movie and
you went oh I gotta make a change what
was it really that's infusion that was
his as well I don't know what it was
that that's interesting what about it
master
it's a great movie mask it's a great
movie what was it was it because he was
different the different thing than the
love story and then also music Danny
Elfman do the music was amazing Oh Danny
Elfman yeah a giant yeah what about you
Kat that's interesting cat and I'm not
mean to answer from the V it's a
rillette I was not expecting that
Edward scissors and cat I think it was
Radio the Cuba Gooding jr. one there was
the first movie with the weird though
yeah and that's the first movie that
ever made me cry and I was so
embarrassed watching it with my mom that
I was crying I don't highlighter I was
like oh he's kind of yeah he's like oh
he's a special he's like simple Jack yes
if you want me to not watch a movie you
have an actor you have an actor do that
and I'll never watch it know that I
don't you're talking about that when I'm
sure he's great oh he really went on a
limb here though yeah I'm sure he was
amazing I think I'm really he really
pushes his there's
Scotch he's simple Jack watch lately the
radio never seen that never snow simple
Jax Ben Stiller in was that a comedy or
a sense no no he simply picked thunder
Tropic Thunder that's him oh yeah I'll
never watch that and Sean did Sean Penn
did a movie right but that's all funny
right yeah that's so Sean Penn did a
movie like that he played uh mentally
yeah will ever watch it I don't know why
but I can't watch it those movies not
because they move me I just can't watch
[ __ ] all over cats can't watch no no but
God bless why did you change your life
cool think it necessary changed my life
it was the first time I watched
something that made me cry I am Sam it
was when he lost his mom and I was
watching with my mom I I was a kid the
Lion King got me when that come out you
let me see how old I was 17 when did
they come out but I kept chasing up when
his dad passes away so I'm super close
to my dad I remember that got me I'm
trying to think what man you were crying
at least seven dude you know when that
was 25th anniversary yes 25 years ago
1994 1994 I was 11
there you go that makes sense they were
joking 11 I was super set I was like 38
so that's um but I was a great movie for
the new large Jeremy Irons I'm excited
for the new one that's dropping soon
that's kids kind of into it what about
you do you have them besides that what
was it but the first one movies don't
really I'm not like I need to get my
[ __ ] together for me thank you jack
nicholson really never know that's the
story the message not ever I don't look
for movies freely I still shake inspo
when I saw a movie called the [ __ ]
war games no no a Ferris Bueller's Day
Off
because you got to stop and smell the
roses once well but I was young again I
was like what 18 oh yeah whatever works
man I was like oh [ __ ] I gotta wake up
and only follow my heart
otherwise I'm I want to be that guy you
know what else [ __ ] me up Point Break
his friend was a [ __ ] up yeah that's a
great movie baby for Marilla Ferrari
yes God that was a great movie God that
was a great movie Johnny
that was a very good movie haha that
fries class what is his conceit because
half the [ __ ] back how do you think I
shot that with a KITT car obviously yeah
for sure just a fiberglass body wow that
is a great movie I don't know no movie
really racing Bulls why I became an
actor yeah it might be a little cuz
you're an actor so maybe it raising it
makes you want to be a movie an actor
well the first people I said I gotta do
something with my life
Point Blank is gonna be amazing though
you're talking about oh yeah if you see
that with Anthony Mackie the crew frank
grillo you see the trailer ah no no I
didn't know they were redoing it I know
we can't play it but play it for Brennan
for a sec Oh type move to our boy grill
it's a straight-up movies star straight
up stove spray my first I have a gun my
[ __ ] no it's great our boy Frank is a
[ __ ] movie star blowing yeah well you
see boss level that looks really really
good it's gonna be great
he did another movies cuz squirt a
[ __ ] 90 or something I mean he's
killing I love it Ben yeah yeah straight
a movie star you really know legit tough
guy you know you see him all muscular
like why yeah he's killing him yeah with
the way he shoots a gun everything about
this good dude to the best best oh how
was it when Sasso was in here
hilarious singing he drove me crazy at
first and then and then it just kicked
off then we killed of course he showed
up on time only a half hour late and
that's a half hour for wills that's good
it's actually good usually look at an
hour two hours no no it's a stats
astonishing you only play volleyball in
Marina del Rey and each up choosing
three hours late yeah we'd be like oh
we're leaving well yeah it's all low
breeze like I just got here huh drive me
crazy just come eat with us yeah but it
would be dressed to play volleyball
he's always the best yes he by the way
and we started weird he was singing I
was like what's going on maybe he's out
mind and then after 25 minutes he kicks
in [ __ ] genius he's just he to me
here I always say it
he Zack Galifianakis and Artie Lange
before he got into drugs and Will Sasso
the funniest people I've ever met
naturally an off the cuff but will might
be number one like overall if you just
take our grand link the LEAs all this
Julie it's phenomenal and you
yeah well it's okay okay to my Brides
all right I've had my moments I've had
I've had a good run really good read
yeah had a good run
now I'm you you you cuff your pants
that's the new thing uh not really new
it might be going out I don't know oh
you know I want to do I'll start wearing
[ __ ] overalls dude well about it okay
hold the fool kid I listen listen hold
on now you are not a farmer we know that
now you're also 37 37 it's so you're
well 36 you're probably 37 but for
argument's sake you're 37 36 and we're
even beggar argument it's like you're on
for 23 I'm pushing 40 as we say 83 where
you should be 40 so I'm gonna say you're
38 right so you're pushing Ithorian so
we can't do here six II know I'm young
I'm young you're no signo biologically I
you know I did they did my biological
organs you know what they came out of
it's [ __ ] crazy
immortal hey now listen you [ __ ] you
need to you need to not wear overalls I
just feel like you'd be cool I know it
would be looking to Iran if you were on
that dating web site for farmers you for
wolf you don't farmers only as a
cover-up for oh you're just saying I
forgot your oldest [ __ ] list so just
wait Oh name a black farmer farmers no
disease they can't say white only its
farmers only overalls
can I wear him no you do anything well
Brian I would never wear [ __ ]
overalls
you're gonna wear over look at this
[ __ ] thinking about do it you can't
go to Dax Shepard he rocks him all the
time but I don't get at what Andre 3000
a ball
if you wear you should wear overalls
with no shirt underneath no you can't go
don't shirt then you gay porno of cool
but of course you like well you should
have poor areas yeah
think about overall No we'll see
please time he wears him not stop huh
yeah well Kristen Bell takes it she's a
hottie she digs her sense of humor and
his intelligence not as [ __ ] overalls
I don't know man it's working for these
kids
oh man it's like his wardrobe huh it's
like Jay Leno and Anna please easy to
wear that's super easy to have a
built-in Jean up her up I had some when
I was in Middle School I used to wear it
with one one latch on it
leave one off girls used to rock them do
they still I feel like girls do wear
them now but like they never want to
stop for women let's see oh girls like
artsy girls I feel like who say artsy
grass like Grossmann gushin of like I
feel like Halsey would wear overalls do
you know that's bad I approved approval
do you see Halsey on the front cover of
I think Rolling Stone or someone [ __ ]
here sticking out mm-hmm
have you seen that our girl Halsey you
know she's in my top three she's got
armpit hair I don't it wasn't that
noticeable though it was like Lily
doesn't do much for me well no it
doesn't well how do you see Miley
Cyrus's armpit here
now that that's what I think it's long
keep scrolling is fine go an inch in
that's fine yeah that's it where's like
you look at Miley Cyrus's armpit yeah
it's not great
like that's come on she's so painfully
hard I think really yeah she do what she
wants I think it's one of those do what
if she wants um Miley Cyrus yes her
armpit hair is you [ __ ] it rock yep a
lot of women who are by let it rock I
did such hold on I will say this it's
the number one turnoff for me I don't
want to see she dies it - oh all right
that's disgusting right there doesn't do
it for me
right ah
ah god I feel sick
[ __ ] that's III's not my thing
the the I mean there can be anything
least sexy than that on this pie I would
agree with you on that I don't like it I
don't like a lot of hair
I just don't know God what do they think
I don't know it's them it's just not
it's not the but it's not though you
know there's always a European thing a
long time ago more in the 70s and your
women always had our hair really
yeah but not nice can't do it well
sometimes they just they just miss or
like they can't get ready I get that but
when you're I mean making a point weird
how we have hair under our arms women -
it's like what is that Jude Ison might
try make a joke
I saw a grandma the other day with a
straight up mustache oh I was like hey
hey no up top who's that girl right
there cuz I just saw her far-left yeah
her sex pics are out Lorne that Kurdish
girl we talked about last week oh she I
think I did AOL digital and she came in
after me and she had little glasses on
she was like this looking and B she just
released her own sex tape or sex
pictures cuz she getting black yeah
that's right
so she went it [ __ ] it here you go
that's why I'm not watching it I told
people not to I don't look at that [ __ ]
but but wait um there's an incinerator
about that really yeah because initially
people were on her side saying what
happened is wrong and she said that the
FBI found who did the leak and it turns
out to be it's a younger guy so she says
that she doesn't want to press charges
and ruin his life but she also just
released her book so people are you know
I don't know what it is
baby she's being her when somebody
releases pictures of yours maybe you're
missing it she released them no she
released him when they were already out
there no they were out there yeah but
they were gonna be released so was
trying to blind she she said [ __ ] you
all I'm gonna release my own yeah [ __ ]
you my book comes out in two weeks
her book came out I think a couple days
before and she was on the press tour hey
where the pictures awesome does she look
amazing
not gonna look at him but they were good
yeah they were like just topless photo
is nothing too crazy so so yeah she's a
great body
yeah it's not she's gorgeous yeah I saw
her so she came in and I thought that's
what it was so I don't know yeah kinda
it's kind of weird the whole set this
whole situation but it was also really
sad because when she released her book
she talked about being molested by her
father since she was six to like 14 so
that was part of the reason why she
decided to release those photos are and
Whoopi Goldberg said it was her fault or
sign
well I Whoopi Goldberg said that she
shouldn't have had taken those photos
because people are hacking into your
phones 2019 people take pictures you
take also Whoopi you're just mad I won't
see your [ __ ] saggy who's that guy
ex-boyfriend yeah who's those who is
that these great mod sons
is he a musician I think he is a
musician but not a very popular one well
he's targeted no one frenzy double as
Tarzan he's known for what dating her oh
oh he doubles his Tarzan wait look at
his hair look at look at that picture of
him I need a best rocking hurt no go
down there yeah there you go
he looks like someone Denis that's a lot
of nose stuff going on let me see more
picture what so he's just I mean she's
painfully hot
if you decorate yourself as she's an
actor mm-hm she started on Disney
Channel oh wow look at him there that's
interesting let's get that out of here
no doesn't do any drugs yeah we should
get that out of his nose right me did
you start this there's no way she wants
to [ __ ] that I don't know what's going
on Brendon now that you know me I like
crashing that is a no-no they you think
so because he looks like a [ __ ]
walking fish hey what is uh what's his
uh what's going on with his hands
is it a built-in yeah thumbs ups the
thumb is amazing
there's no way she [ __ ] it can't be
that much maybe she just look that's her
thing look at him what movies has she
been
serious besides Disney I don't care
about her at all buddy she has but I
can't off the top of my head list any
she was in a show uh about being a young
Hollywood starlet but she wrote overtly
healthy why would I want to read about
her she has a lot of young follow yeah
she has a very large following because
she started at Disney and then she the
mail 16 up demos not what she's going
[ __ ] me fire truck she was in that
that's a short film I'm a ho - alright
oh yeah she makes music now - um and
that's kind of the gist of what she well
if it is - who I can can you just see if
she did is there any way to see AOL
digital I gotta make sure because I did
she looked at the cameras and how do I
put this how do I put this
it looked so obnoxious is that build
series yeah well three days ago okay so
that was her then I just want to see and
I don't want to say any bad I don't know
she's too young to criticize she's just
worried saying she's just trying to
figure it out it doesn't matter I don't
even know what I'm I don't even know if
I mean what I say scratch it forget it I
don't want to be critical of anybody
that that's too young I'm not doing it
2017 but his boyfriend now he's not
together anymore right I don't think so
yeah well because of that sweater what
is she going to seizure hold on maude
son his name's Ahmad son please go back
I guarantee his real name is John hurt
no that's his music Darren Smith yeah
his band was my son oh there's a rapper
oh no way go to youtube good YouTube
right thank you and go right now is
right now right now don't get us kicked
off online not cyber is now click happy
to million to point far right I'm
[ __ ] horny
happy be be there's a lyric says son
right there with [ __ ] : kendrick
lamar's oh my god this guy is a
nightmare
you guys have lost your son there's
general tattoos not just a bunch of
right yourselves like dad I made a video
let me show you this like oh oh just a
lot of writing it's a lot of decoration
well you pulled that hot ass dime piece
though yeah I wonder what it is maybe
he's awesome a person he's probably good
guy yeah I will say I don't know if you
have this experience when I meet a lot
of these guys I'd never had it like on
them I've never been like a lot of times
I'll meet a dude and you just talk to
him guy but I don't know that's just too
much work I don't know what the [ __ ] to
say well he's a character for she is a
character that's said that's a dude
that's a lot of work though bro for him
isn't it the consideration scene kids
like alright but but like the amount of
the amount of like trying to look as
cool as possible that's not the tough
way here dude that's a tough walk that's
that has to be done in a mirror for a
long time or not or not well that's all
considered that's it that's deep
affectation yes he has issues living oh
oh oh it's a video
that's my rap videos I spent too much
time on both of them I mean he's doing
something right
maybe but are they still hot girl just
broke up she why do you look like she's
holding him alright guys well yeah I've
never heard of either of them I just got
privy to her because of the sex stuff
how's it go who's this Jake
yeah young young people trying to work
it out um yeah she's figuring out man
that's all well good enough with her
what were we talking about what deep
[ __ ] were we talking about
did you watch the poly mouth Raji
yeah broke his hand the second round
hard to hit though how did you well yeah
yeah listen I actually had him winning
the foot I even though he was using one
hand I actually had him he hit Artem
more aren't him hit him in the body we
know he was there copy strike numbers to
look for if so I don't think the people
keeps saying that and I actually had
Polly winning - you know what my thing
is is they coulda gave to either one
when they get to Artem like yeah that's
yeah I listen clear-cut winner I would
like to see nah Paulie not have a broken
hand see how he would I also like I also
think Paulie was very tentative in
fighting like a boxer at 12 rounds like
you don't have time there two-minute
rounds you gotta go you gotta go
so I thought Arden was tentative I
thought Paulie was tentative you got he
kind of got a bad product but Paulie is
an outstanding analyst is he a color the
best what do you call the caller a the
best he's as good as it gets
so he's got this great career stay there
but you make it he made good money doing
this one whose ass crime fighting next
did oz at all Yahoo I saw it I said
punch stats well when you were typing it
in all robach gin cuz I put that in um
there it goes there those me nothing
came up I'd be interested in numbers
people see keep saying that but I don't
know Paulie Paulie wasn't that active
he's on a back foot and throwing jabs
didn't use his right hand it's not
assumed if when we look at numbers hard
and bright land you said to me that his
you you thought his hands were gonna be
a major liability yeah yep my prediction
was Paulie pieces them up early on the
brakes a hand and then arm winds did be
a distinct a scene to have made up and
buried the hatchet as it were yeah
there's no numbers right like bare
knuckles I do [ __ ] Tommy strike
official numbers
I had no problem with either decision I
thought was more of a bummer there's no
clear-cut winner right well [ __ ] it
move it on yeah it's fun though
I bet more people watch set than the UFC
or Bellator yeah that's crazy right
that is nuts that's [ __ ] nuts do we
does the we numbers in views where it is
Val to our stack up with us see some of
the cards beat them some dope I mean in
general so there's Mac in that
competitors no no but some of their
cards beat him right Bellator pays their
fighters better I would imagine right we
don't know no I mean it's all the same
you know no one's root you know um but
they're allowed to have sponsors so they
can make some money that I thought
bare-knuckles fun yeah well you smile
like that nothing I'm thinking about
radio voice Carter one their boy Dakota
one yep I did some celebrating yeah look
great - I did some celebrating after
beat Johnny Hendrix maybe dis dude man
[ __ ] Christian Hey look right tough
there's one of our bare knuckle goes
from here I don't know it doesn't know I
know it turns into boxing no you can't
do it like that I mean you know they got
to keep it like a little bit guerilla
style like you don't want to mark it
this should I don't think you should
have any belts I think should be like
gorillas well I mean it's like if I may
rather watch boxing than bare-knuckle
would you yeah well there's one of the
best box on earth fight you watch it
what Paulie no charlo fought I think we
see him no no I know you're watching
beer know about oh [ __ ] because all you
talk about is beer now watch I'll watch
Charlotte Sharla
no it's over you missed it you can watch
it on Showtime it's not your time oh
it's not no listen you're all your dhaba
so this is the thing though oh no I'm a
boxing fans you mean I'm a huge bomb
singer but yeah we were so I want to
roll yeah because they were so much bad
blood but no because it's different -
yeah like it I just wonder like you know
like there's some great box on this
weekend there's some amazing MMA fights
but all anybody cared about was this
bare-knuckle yeah
you know yeah yeah for now I'll still
I'll get that out of my system and go
right back to boxing I feel like Ivy
Tech will get diverted periodically I'll
go over here then we'll come back to
boxing I think boxing is always here to
stay we have been over 200 years yeah
but what I'm saying is you don't have to
pick why would you pick it's always
weird when people do that like you know
you can watch UFC and box no but I mean
because because bare-knuckle is to me
lower level rudimentary boxing it's not
the same like I love watching the boxing
gloves and all that it's just more
interesting about over the same sport
you know it's kind of just like no but I
feel like bare-knuckle is kind of the
garage version of real boxing that's
probably this and it feels like it's
low-rent
it makes me a little more sure it's
uncool ya know for all for sure yeah
yeah but it's also guys past their prime
that's the other guy it's all like
that's the other know every wants to
beat around the bush but it's like old
you do to her way past their prime
fighting bare-knuckle where it's there's
something savage about it yeah I don't
yeah I don't know how big it's gonna get
I don't know like I'm not throwing at
them I don't like Jason Knight and I
think I don't see you know I think it's
just there yeah but also their family
box box and Pearce didn't watch the
fight right boxing fans aren't gonna
watch right MMA Fame that's right
the young crowds gonna watch it but I
were gonna wait rather watch MMA yeah
but yeah but and I think but this
weekend you did it neither did I did not
hmm Charla fought when best boxers on
planet earth to amaze Charlotte when he
fights triple G or someone like that
charlo psycho I think the older their
they both fight what 160 and what the
hell 155 no yeah and one way to you when
Adam they're big guys why do they prefer
it for that weight class but here's the
thing you wouldn't watch charla fight
the guy who he fought over Paulie verse
Artem no but I would I'd watch Charlie
fight you know oh I'll send him on
Canelo
is that gonna happen I think that's so
much work to do dude here's the thing B
would you watch France gah no
by anti Rumble Johnson bare-knuckle over
that
I can't do that today fair but you'd
watch it right we all have we all would
yeah if they can leave 42 names like
that those two are gonna watch it out
over anything cuz somebody might you
know watch out it's so barbaric and
gladiator all those guys oh my god if
you got like that and Rumble Johnson is
doing better not cry hurt no he's just
like brand assets oh okay but I'm sure
you could get him out to do it
I just got me excited and it's never
happening I'm just saying if they if
they can line up the right fights you're
gonna watch that over anything really
because it's so raw correct yes yes and
we're Psychopaths manthang Johnson's a
big kid yeah yeah you don't need go
don't you be a big dude he's thick right
now he's a thick he he's even thicker
now dude yeah well shout to them shoot
he's the boy I shouldn't worry he was
walking about 2:35 he's gonna suck down
to 170 those were bad days for him yeah
shirt off and I'm looking at my me I
will I said the Sam Sheridan I go I'm
depressed
he goes hey shut up man no but I want to
look like that he goes what's never
gonna happen so don't do that
Lateline all right you know what he got
Corvettes yeah all right you know be
it's time you work out hard dude hard
bro you need something to keep up with
you something cuz you wear these other
shoes and workout gear and it breaks
down where you know I wear my clothing
and my stuff heart and it you'll blow
through it you'll rip through it that's
right your shoes fall off
not any - ain't built to perform Rock
dude I need something that's gonna keep
up with it you're talking about no bull
it's a footwear apparel accessory brand
for people who train hard like you and
don't believe in excuses all right
athlete now I know this is why no Bulls
for you it's on a mission to create a
product that's built for people who
train hard I need to a funk house
designed today and performance though
dude
I don't need gimmicks I don't need
excuses I just need thoughtful and
durable products built for people who
train hard I train hard dude I got you
you train hard you need know
and they got all sorts of trainers
runners they got a car and I waited I
got you bro they got the best
cross-training shoes in the business for
reals actually really love workout these
shoes that listen for simple durable
functional training gear visit no bull
project.com slash fighter training gear
for people who work hard and don't
believe in excuses like my friend over
here know most progeny fact nine years
old he pushes hard it's in no-bull visit
no bull project calm slash fighter get
your gear today that's n OB u ll p ro je
CT dot-com slash fighter you want to
know where you came from I mean really
came from Jimmy let me talk to you about
ancestry I know because I've been going
through the history books trying to find
out where I'm from dude
answers are my family's white and I'm
brown I know ancestry DNA can actually
the place in the world where your story
started and they use precise geographic
detail clear-cut historical insights you
can even trace your ancestors journeys
over time you can get active family
trees they take DNA results for over 100
million family trees and billions of
records to give you more insight into
your genealogy and origins and only
ancestry can tell such a rich story with
unique features that give you a complete
picture about yourself who doesn't want
to know more about yourself and it's
easy sound excited about this it's easy
to get started dude good ancestry.com
slash fat K F 80 K today for 20% off
your ancestry DNA kit that's
ancestry.com slash fat K for 20% off
your ancestry DNA kit dude I can't wait
to enhance my DNA experience and learn
about my complete history that's
ancestry.com /f 80 K for 20% off your
ancestry DNA kit right now juicing Quran
events ok media on the 25th anniversary
of his ex-wife's killing OJ decided to
join social media and he released a
video but he's really Stu since right
mm-hmm
did what here's my thing yeah I think
you
$700,000 $800,000 who the [ __ ]
following him have you seen the comments
people who are like oh there's not one
positive well no no one's like dude keep
on keepin on like everyone's all sending
pictures of the murder theme and like
you get away with murder
lay low Amiga I would double murder I
would lay low but he takes lots of
pictures with people and I mean well a
lot of people want to take pictures with
him that's why let's see yeah some how
Cullen show threat let me see balls
they're so creepy
hey Twitter world is yours truly hey
Twitter world soon to Twitter you'll get
to read all my thoughts and opinions so
just about everything now there's a lot
of fake oj accounts out there so this
one at the real oj 32 is the only
official one so it should be a lot of
fun I got a little getting even to do so
god bless take care getting even see
this how are people like out in and out
cotton so we're cool but let's cut out
the game even part huh
hey Twitter world you know for years
people have been able to say whatever
they want to say about me with no
accountability I'll be able to talk
about everything especially sports
fantasy football and even politics but
for now let me just say is out there
happy Father's Day your thoughts on her
being renewed for season six very feud
people are [ __ ] lighten them up like
much like if double-murder
can't really [ __ ] with it man hello
Twitter world why this Twitter world if
you're you you studied him you watch the
demo and Twitter world what is he a
sociopath yeah yeah for sure
his was a crime of passion clearly and
that the dude in it was just a bystander
he's not gonna be there yeah he's
definitely going to kill Nicole she had
all the signs I mean if you talk to well
he used to be yeah right there was not
be the experts who like know murdered
that I call this the Claire's there was
a pattern and then fine Hatter and
apparently his sister her sister said he
did it he did it or something like that
no I mean I think everyone said he did
it no I mean when she found out he
finally screaming he did it but a lot
even her family her sit yeah her sister
went he did it zomb out yes whole brand
all dances yeah she said he did it and
then they're saying like the first hit
like a regular murderer like they're
gonna kill you but the the amount of
anger and passion that he had as many
times as she was stabbed in the eye yes
that's not the initial hit they said to
hit her so hard I'm a severed her head
that's not a normal like that's not like
someone be like oh let me just kill you
real quick that's like that's a passion
like anger is built up right you thought
you were cheating on him
the dude drove over there just to drop
off her glasses he's a victim of it so
you know it's crazy though right there
they look so much alike to her sister
kind of man yeah hello Twitter world
mighty hello Twitter world and Paul even
politics I get a lot of evening I gotta
get even whatever they want to say okay
oh God but he did he did post one about
the Kardashians sue I'm dressing like
Khloe Kardashian do you know everyone
says that's his like he's the biologic
you think now y'all y'all need to stop
with that do the Kardashians now this is
smart because he wants to so she self
with the Kardashians because they have
such a big following he knew this to get
picked up everything is calculated that
he's doing huh
I can listen these all day restart chin
hello world this is my first venture
into the social media world
it's amazing you're saying world
especially how quickly they could put up
counterfeit sites anyway we'll deal with
that um my life has always been involved
in the sports world and I suspect as a
week schools long that's pretty much
what we'll be talking about but once in
a while I'm gonna go off talk the topic
and talk about something else and this
is one of those times you know Bob could
Aston is like a brother to me
he's a great guy he met married Chris
and they've really had a terrific time
together when they were together
unfortunately that ended but never then
I wanna stress never in any way shape or
form have I ever had any interest in
Chris romantically or sexually and I
well that's that's an indication that
she had any interest in me so all of
these stories are just bogus that's not
new Matt you know tasteless Chloe like
all the girls I'm very proud of just
like I know Bob would be if he was here
but the simple fact of the matter is
she's not mine now one of the people who
spreading this rumor is a guy that the
media loves to say is my manager I have
one manager in my whole life Chuck
Barnes when I came out of USC for three
years unfortunately he died about 45
years ago before you down Peter he was
my first date with my bare hands and his
heart stopped it was such there's really
no Brian the late bear little Bonnie you
can stop at Genesis bro yeah hello
Twitter world why do you say it wasn't
true that he and because he's on tape
time how he [ __ ] kris kardashian on
tape and didn't know there's cameras
then he goes sees cameras now he'll not
win the world to the camera off don't be
filming this for the world
yeah sorry Wescott yeah he describes
they're in a hot tub he drops his pants
and [ __ ] it every she was not a writer
said that that was a story she was hot
when she was younger
sure of her when she was young dude
she's 70 now still 417 shoots pretty
good I agree 100% when she was younger
she must have been a complete [ __ ]
dime piece coming yeah she got her
Nicole Brown one
downtown they were best friends to smoke
shows yeah dude she's seven not dance
feels like [ __ ] but Jude they're 100%
she had a great body check out the body
on Bruce
she's got a nice nice body too Bruce
just dying inside right now
Bruce died say my face looks happy my
heart really just like huh
there's a little sad man English under
his time [ __ ] in here under his tongue
isn't mad little man crying dude you
were the first ever person to call it
yes I was there we all roasted you for
oh I don't know seven hours right now
you know I got a friend who was painting
the house said they saw him in drag and
clothes on the floor I just knew from we
like get the [ __ ] out her and then I saw
him at Starbucks when like the rumors
going around he had long hair I'm gonna
look at his hands her hands at this
thing or his hands at the time I was
like God have some nice s yeah you pick
up on that stand
I'm like that ponytails [ __ ] well I
know also like he used to come to my my
kids for a little bit went to the same
school as his and he would show up in
bracelets and there was just like a
little makeup on and they were like aw
he's mmm interesting he's he was always
feminizing his looks you can see it got
here's a timepiece
well Olympic gold before he had his nose
on short before he had his [ __ ] nose
with his nose done there
oh yes nose Tydeus dude as he got older
with all the work he had he's a better
looking woman I know look at it when he
was young he was such a stud son just
come on he looked come on knock on the
right well he had his nose pinched been
a great nose why would you do that
because he wanted to be a woman but he
was like he was a look at that he ruined
his face with that stupid nose job
I mean I mean come on Sergei on the
right there but he was such a stud dude
he was a stud ah built to like a brick
[ __ ] a very strange man bring up
his paw but good for him good for him
bring up his body he sees living his
truth I see the short shorts man
yeah look at him when he was younger go
go back just where he's where he wins
that [ __ ] this one right there yeah
that's the famous one I was like some
short story so they still run in those
now
yeah gotta have them talking about such
a fancy as we were there but yeah you
dude do not crazy just roaring on the
inside to be a girl
roaring roaring just you know ah well
there we go great shorts great shorts
and a great I remember those mid-drift
shirts please wear that run please you
can get away football players you know
they ban them from football players well
I used to have it but they got rid of
them in college like FSU used to be like
I remember or I mercy out of them how
come I don't know I think they thought
it was gay there's some things that are
just so gay that even given us each
others all nah man
why just gay you know yeah some things
that wait there's a Sports Illustrated
cover of uh all right what else we got
here's a piece look it out down there
good out there what can speak that one's
not is no that one's not now their mom
was a smoke show yeah her Nicole Brown
run around Brentwood slaying dick yeah
Oh Jay offset Oh Jay got upset but else
who yet I love that he's on social media
I don't follow him to the most
sociopaths but I like the up yeah hello
that's what a world
conservative Oh real quick
what what candidate is uh OJ gonna what
candidate is he gonna go for it's not
gonna hope that can't okay yeah oh I'm
sure it's Trump you know she'll smile oh
you're right though right I get the
endorsement yeah you don't want his if
he goes after the gay dude yet he's like
no no no don't please don't say anything
all right what else we got
well this is not good so this man in
Arizona decapitated his roommates dog's
head as she was moving out because he
says that she owes him and his mother
money for rent well there might be a
first sign this is the first sign that
you got a straight-up killer on yes
Julie does that to animals Disney
regards times a first sign that they're
sociopaths
apparently he's done this in the past
where he's captured animals from his
local neighborhood and has murdered them
and basically says a few hours later the
woman and the others who were helping
her pack her belongings saw beg amazed
take a small box into a truck when asked
what it was in the box the woman said
Begum as smiled at her when she opened
the Box found her dead mutilated
headless dog inside Wow
she they said that she was so in shock
but she couldn't report it until the
next day police said Vega Meza hate his
name admitted to wrapping the dog with
string and cutting it with a razor blade
well this guy's are sold out so that's
not like that's a yeah this is serial
killer this is athis he sure they need a
lock him up now I think he should be
killed up now this is kind of guy this
should be killed because he's he's
practicing like it's a very bad guy cuz
if you can do that and you have no
problem kids oh yeah
if no conscious and yep you have no
remorse like did humans are next
you know much razor blade these are what
these people do though man I know men
look what it says here to when
describing what he did to the animals
police said he laughed so you just
completely I'm a cop is a tough job
[ __ ] tough job where you do deal with
these maniacs and you gotta let go if
you want a bike you can't put them in
prison for how long actually you do he
could do seven years for this for her
young this could come with a seven year
or eight year sentence and you're not
getting a job after this yeah well
that's the problem okay so you cut a
dog's head off let's put you away for
seven years she's 24 so you get out when
you're 31 and your worst hold on can't
get a job institutionalize your
professed you have your black belt in
criminal now right being a criminal you
get your back folks you're around a
bunch of other crime dudes and you get
out can't get a job yeah you upset at
the world no girls gonna [ __ ] you so you
start cutting people's heads off there's
your next serial killer leave that
[ __ ] psycho Jesus Christ men what
else you got
terrible huh yeah so this is another
downer unfortunately there is a couple
in Pennsylvania who's being charged with
sexual abuse of a minor so they're the
husband in this case was a band teacher
and he started to have a sexual
relationship with one of his students
when she was 16 and it got to the point
where both the wife and the husband
would text the sixteen-year-old girl and
the wife would encourage her to sleep
with her husband to say that he needs to
get it out of his system now would that
because they're a [ __ ] if a wife is that
is that a cut well what else is called a
couple that likes bringing young girls
in and [ __ ] what what what city are
they in though uh sixteen can kind of
it's a tricky line tricky line I guess
I'm not saying I approve it Greenfields
Township not go on a County districts
office likewise a laka wanna love man
she can't be six ever be careful wanna
yeah gotta be careful in Lackawanna
Lakeland High School has been spent
Lakeland High School it might be Chicago
outside Chicago Lakeland am I right on
that chin taco wanna I'm gonna say
Illinois Pennsylvania Pennsylvania since
she said Pennsylvania couple in the
beginning lotta wanna well I don't know
what the average age yeah well yeah so
what is so the both of them are [ __ ]
yeah both I see the girl though you know
I've seen some six knows I'm like why
they look every bit at 40 24 no it's
true ah I'm still upset about that guy
who cut that dog's head I want to I know
it's scary man oh definitely it was out
he's gonna what do we do about that you
can't dude the cops have dude you should
be each fight crime
I'm a little old for it but fight crime
I'm gonna buy Cape and I'm pretty quick
I I did some batting I'm dissing batting
I hit a baseball
that came out okay yeah it was a sixty
miles I did some
having a cage it's a batting cage the
ball is at 60 miles an hour
daddy connected I was surprised my bad
speed I have it on video it's so slow
it's depressing I should send it to you
so you can see how slow 16 yeah the only
reason I was able to hit it I've done
that and I was so sixty would be by the
school level yeah it's the wall it's 14
years old yeah middle school and and I
could hit it only because I play tennis
- the ball comes over that way 60 I
can't imagine 80 or no you didn't turn
it up higher I could have turned it to
up to 70 but I hurt my [ __ ] hands I
hit up and the vibration killed me I
just said it - okay
and it was like ow [ __ ] so um have you
when was last time you had a batting
cage been a while yeah but we didn't
start at 60 what did you start at well
grown-ups high speed no and ISO 60 super
slow dude that's middle-school speed so
when you go out daddy hit it well well
yeah yeah 12 year-old throwing balls bro
no oh you owe your bragging a little bit
you get a ball at 50 years old off a 12
yeah oh I'll tell you this I was at my
boys he's got this high-end gym my buddy
Kevin Bay at hybrid cross phrase gonna
be mad at me fine hybrid fit fitness
whatever is any way they treat they they
train the high school kids going into
college
the 18 year olds 17 18 year olds [ __ ]
huge these days oh my god just huge and
strong I was like how is that kid kids
17 what are you talking monsters you're
[ __ ] monsters dude I can't believe
you bragged about in this six bring this
out though cuz you're gonna be impressed
give it a few seconds its intake yeah
yeah no but it's dude no little practice
I'm playing hard pitch ball maybe dear
I'm saying she's joined a softball
league if I can stop by laugh at I laugh
at that cuz I hit every time sixty I
don't know if you're gonna throw machine
if you can throw me throw junk don't
throw down the pike because I'm gonna
hit it you know I'm saying especially at
60 from a 12 year old
you know what bring it up a couple miles
an hour I don't give off I can't believe
he didn't who was like let's start at 60
I don't I'm just what they put it on
because I've never I haven't I haven't
swung a bat since I was literally eight
III lose I just followed watch watch my
tape watch how slow this is do that so
slow I haven't shown dude why would you
sell my oh it's so slow dude I was so
depressed I mean me and I was a little
nervous it's all my elbow should be
higher I think oh man they're good for
you to be least you gotta get some
exercise
thanks buddy it's cool man dude I'm
hitting no huh I'm connecting do you
think I have potential you do man I
think you should look and say it with a
straight face no do it man say it with a
straight leg not bitching see some
connecting my lecture I I was so
depressed I saw I was like my bat slow
slow but I was probably doing it I was
it was slow because I was tired as time
it mad you brought that up to brag
you're lucky you told me the speed too
because I would have made a lot worse
see she got out the other exercises oh
man looks like Hanks buddy pronounced my
calories bro seriously thanks [ __ ] off
dude you look like you go to go to one
the real fast [ __ ] ones that the pro is
lazy you're not sniffing it
you're not sniff out I scared old one
off and it was a victory oh yeah freaky
let's see laws now or some [ __ ] hey
eighty would be high school level high
school there's kids dropping nineties
bro and then the pros let's throw some
junk on it oh right in 60 no one's
throwing city you want to through it
some junk on it you're not gonna leave
the ball well if it comes out here
no I'm afraid you I'm telling I died it
was I'm talking damn there and possible
I was like oh well how does someone hit
this in the browser yeah and that in the
coach I was I was at USC I'm the
professional Madden guys and I went oh
my and I went this how it looks yes yeah
but look the balls he is gonna come
right here right here Brendan so just
try and hit it and do this [ __ ] god I
felt its come off you're in the bat
speed basically right or what you
couldn't be the bat around in time I
mean again I've been bad and forever
yeah but I was connecting but it's just
fouling but then that's after like 30
strikeouts now imagine them throwing
[ __ ] junk at you chunk I'm I'm
hitting it maybe well that's why maybe
one out of ten dude if you if you're a
pro you hit three out of ten you're on
the whole thing that's so crazy aim of
lose it yeah it's a game of like
basically gonna be so strong here and
then home runs well that's why they
would always give Alex Rodriguez so much
[ __ ] when he's strike out on the
playoffs in seven I was like I mean [ __ ]
you guys when Kurt Angle and bro and
when Kurt Schilling a long time ago was
pitching and he would pitch this sinker
or slide or whatever his curveball it
was it would get end up at your feet
dude it's a guy goes the guy goes he was
struck out everybody everybody everybody
and they go what are you gonna do this
later goes what are you gonna do I get
them hitting baseballs is [ __ ] nuts
okay at that high level [ __ ] what else
get you home so a man in Florida is
currently being held to on charges of
burglary as well as Grand Theft Auto he
went to trial and before the jury were
able to get to their seats
he flung poop at the judge and said eat
it it's protein it's good for you and he
continued to then eat his poop oh yes
and this isn't out of the ordinary
because a couple days before he actually
covered himself in his own poop while he
was in jail so this is a common
occurrence
did he we're talking a turd yes ah makes
me feel sick maybe he's trying to plead
for insanity though yeah that's what he
tried but they deemed that he was
healthy to stand trial waited for
burglary though Oh
acquitted yeah he stole on the chart
still
facing charges you are throwing [ __ ]
yeah dude if you ain't a piece of [ __ ]
like I he's insane
[ __ ] dude did you I never laid some more
Mouse do you see that guy at TSA freaked
the [ __ ] out it took 30 TSA people to
control him
no he's like staying lying they just
like no [ __ ] huge like [ __ ] and
that some lady's just standing there it
goes and then it takes like 12 Surtur
TSA yeah I was just in Phoenix Airport I
was just there
where's the this is before you can be
yeah I think it was like on Thursday
lucky for him could start your [ __ ]
superhero I'm fighting that would I put
him at doosh doosh doosh boom that lady
eats it at the end dude he's just like
you know what it's not about tell my
shoes off good guy you exhale yeah push
through passengers way lying knocked a
female tisket to the ground for a bad
day you know what just have a bad date
and find what [ __ ] it drugs and alcohol
drugs for sure is that what they said
yeah look at the shitty takedown attempt
by the first guy look oh wait you tell
me they're not trained professionals
that's why cuz they saw my crap that
dude tried to [ __ ] tackle I'm at
least and held on oh is that the first
ones delirious watch the first guy know
this guy this guy look oh he's all hold
on oh him dude oh this guy gets him in
no nope doesn't work on that from the
back he comes back he's tough
better than that [ __ ] policeman he
was he checked in the school he had a
psychotic episode is that what they said
she said just high on drugs and alcohol
you know and you're like God customs
there's nothing can do you know TSA
doesn't matter you just lost your phobic
and you're on your way I just panic all
night on Saturday night on all Nightline
no sleep Bryan Callen you
yes why because I get done with meet and
greet at 1:30 my flight was at 6 a.m.
and weirdly I get back to the room it's
like 1:45 and the guy dropped me off he
goes
so seem about 2 hours on it why he's
your flights at sixth international we
gotta get you a two hours really went oh
okay well I can't fall asleep because I
thought yeah so I just laid in bed with
my [ __ ] sweating that's done it I've
been there felts don't realize how that
is you wake up miss one night of sleep
see how you function it's amazing how
delicate oh dude I wanted to pull what
this guy did to the [ __ ] flight
attendant I fall asleep you know tired I
was I got the plane first one I'm like
I'm just gonna go to sleep I'm out man
then excuse me sir sir like I'm such a
deep sleep I was a wide she goes can I
get you something to drink
oh no I sorta I went why she was scared
I'm like kinda out of like I just can I
would you like something to drink on it
well no no no no no I'm sleeping but I'm
sleeping [ __ ] man
I've been nervous that's that's insane
that's insane
you and I having a dog's head off and
waking me up out of a deep sleep those
are two [ __ ] things I think I'm all
set on juice yeah there are two things
that you should probably go to jail for
for a girl like that I just remembered
that I'm so enraged right now and then I
told her I went uh is it it's I'm sorry
let me is it normal
free to wake somebody up who's dead
asleep
I mean Razzie goes yeah you know you
should have told us not to wake you
I'm in REM sleep I want you as people
get upset if they skip our food and
drink service went oh okay okay
you woke me up for your airplane food
did you make it yourself in your
state-of-the-art kitchen huh
does it come with a shitty salad that
looks like it's made from wax did I just
remember that happened I was like why
can you microwave that little [ __ ] Eli
dinner a bad fridge
you see I finally got rest and you wake
me up for your
JT drinks the nerve and the flight was
in full at all I was by myself up there
yeah you're a by yourself I just
remembered
yeah dude I don't use it what I mean it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you work for animals
and you clean up you should go to Carol
sorry dude yes dude take it easy I never
fly Air Canada no no come on man just
give them another chance dude nothing
drives you more nuts especially comics
and celebrities tweet about [ __ ]
Airlines up [ __ ] up their day they're
talking worse they're trying to get that
back doesn't matter though you know
doesn't matter hey doesn't matter I
compile doesn't matter does not matter
in fact but it just doesn't you know
they don't care if I could walk I Drive
there would you just the Greyhound I'm
man that really pissed me off I will
never forget that you know I fell back
asleep thank God fell back asleep man
you give - you give Spanx - Carla dollar
I'd [ __ ] fell back asleep but dude yeah
she's lucky I did she's lucky she's
lucky I did so when you're that tired
yeah I don't know I don't know what
would a lucky I don't know what that's
personís all straight up read in a long
time and it put me right - it makes me
so angry
it's like you know I was like I couldn't
believe I didn't I thought I was
dreaming I'm talking about like sir and
keep saying me like what you think yeah
well I I answer with why can I get you a
beverage you find the first thing I do
if you gave me a lot of money you know I
might as I'd fly I'd show private jet no
I sure went I'll take a hot coffee make
sure it's hot thank you I'd like a hot
coffee in thrown in your face please I'm
sorry you woke me up for my deep slumber
I need nothing god this reminds me of a
guy who was a Chinese prisoner of war in
a Japanese prison camp I don't know why
this told laters for my sure a my fellow
really I'm gonna have to walk in a
single line yeah there's so there's
waking up like that and
being a Japanese prisoner of war camp
where you work all day and as you walk
by they would pour they'd have a
scalding cup thing of soup and they'd
take a ladle and you'd have to open your
mouth and they'd pour it in your mouth
or in your mouth but it's only calories
you could get that's how I felt that's a
great example that's exactly I felt
that's a good time pour hot [ __ ] soup
down my throat yeah might as well done
that mmm you [ __ ] what else we got
make sure you believe perfect timing
well speaking of Airlines Cam Newton was
on a flight from Paris back to the US
and it was a packed flight because of
the soccer football games happening and
happening abroad it was a football boom
yeah yeah and he actually went up to a
gentleman and offered $1500 for a seat
because I had more legroom and the guy
declined there was video of this and it
just went viral
it was awesome by the way first of all
worth it second when you're that tall
and you have that money worth it but
also why is he flying first-class yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah that's
another thing he's probably late booking
cuz yeah oh excuse me he has so much
money so much excuse me he's one of the
biggest contracts of all time before
they changed the rules first-round draft
I liked it he forfeited he's a smart guy
$1,500 yeah what [ __ ]
um I applaud him offering the money [ __ ]
yeah he was like you know what this is a
capitalist world let me [ __ ] pay for
a better seat I don't want to sit he's a
giant he's a [ __ ] giant he's got to
sit in there for how long eleven hours
ten hours that's how he must have booked
it late and it was just like go playing
you up for someone on the plane that's
have oh you like some news really I mean
I see people offer people money I mean I
would do that in are some people were
saying is too little considering how
much money he has like he should they
gave more yeah but is it 1500 enough for
you guys to move your seats
I'd attend our father would have done it
now yeah exactly
but 15 grand he shot him he should offer
five juice.5 his money as big as he is
five g's and i would be like but he's
also my PA I was like you know what
that's a lot of money to suffer for
eleven hours I he's big though that's
not comfortable for him live at all
hmm he's also wide how about the guy was
like nah bro I'm good you know he felt
pressure alright maybe he didn't mean
you don't know who the [ __ ] he is but he
knew who he was like yeah yeah I would
have done this
you woulda gave me watch you want a game
you sass me ask me yo man if I take your
seat old man ah
well I come on browse the first pick in
the draft
you come on man my knees are [ __ ] up
from scoring touchdowns this past season
I'll do my line see sir asked me again
hey I know it's him ready yeah you know
it's him a lot d Lambert oh no sir it's
a hybrid that's how I write our hangout
what oh you suck math - what did you ask
me flight not straight I'm straight I'm
flight in the sub huh lightness oh no
way we can fit in that bathroom I know
we'll figure it out I'll do right yeah
you give him your seat first off 100%
and I wouldn't take his money I'll be
like you're huge of course you can sit
here if I can feel your muscles Oh
whenever whenever I'm in first class if
there's a prep if is a pregnant lady by
yourself or with a kid I can all offer
them my see oh you do
everytime I wait for them to come by
every time really it's rare there but
the problem is if they're with a family
that I yeah it's [ __ ] up but if if I
see one by himself and a kid I was
giving I've never done that I always do
really always I've never done it now I'm
sure now I'm probably gonna have to but
I would do it I would do it now you
wouldn't but you know soon I don't take
my things every day my belly my thing
dude my thing no but I wanted to know I
want to out virtue you know well do it
for black people
every time black person comes on give me
[ __ ] see yo it to him what's that you
don't thought about okay yo it tone yo
it to him
yo it does reparations don't
reparations for your don't unders how do
you think of that by the way I don't
want to get you in trouble here the
terrible idea
reparations operations who's gonna pay
it that's is I mean told you out we want
to go to how far we go back yeah because
it did cuz did mmm this dicey we move on
for I'm saying how far back
slavery did start in Africa slavery was
Oliver world wall over Y so does England
cuz England was damn good at slavery
yeah yeah so was the Ottoman Empire so
was the Mongols the child is an Africa
itself South Africa is really good at it
and a lot of Africans it was the way it
was the order of the day right yeah just
do white supremacists on for reparations
I don't think it's dawning is helpful to
I don't think it solves a problem you
know I think it's well but did you see
Tyler Perry's speech last night hmm
Oh doggy look it up look at [ __ ] up
chin Tyler Perry wins the icon of the
Year award he has the great story I you
know I don't [ __ ] with a religious thing
aspect of it
his story is fit was very good I'm very
good back did you ever listen to it love
team will be I'll play the audio right
gin will get a shot but not that the
YouTube Oh far away to go in four
minutes and 30 SEC
go pass Hershey's blah blah blah
solution suck em off Roger
yeah she's period so just beat a smart
guy playing that Drizzy from he's very
smart tie Paris Paris billionaire great
speech and usually I fast forward to the
speeches when I came in no I thought the
same Lee Daniels are thinking if I think
he's not getting our kids all right
listen this is worth listening to
I want to say a special thanks to BT my
new family I can't wait to get started
over there with our new shows thank you
so much for this
to Scott and everybody over there thank
you so much to Viacom Shirey who's here
Bob everybody listen from my heart I
want to say thank you I couldn't help
but think about my mother sit down sit
down sit down hey smart guy never think
about my mother no I remember being a
kid about five years old she would take
me into the projects with her when she
played cards from Friday nights with a
bunch of women now these women didn't
have more than a 12th grade education
but they were smart black women they
were powerful black women
they had great stories to tell and I was
a 5 year old kid sitting there on the
floor playing with my Matchbox cars
listening to them talk about their men
their relationships and their pains and
when one of them would get really sad
another woman would come in and make a
joke and they'd all start laughing I
didn't know I was in a master class for
my life Wow at home and my father would
be beating my mother and doing all kinds
of things and saying all kinds of stuff
to her and he would leave the room and
I'd walk in and I didn't imitate one of
those women and she would start laughing
damn I was a power in that that I didn't
really get until I got older I remember
being about 11 12 years old on my way to
my new school and I got to this
intersection I had to walk past pimps
prostitutes walk through literally
walked through a graveyard get to this
intersection six lane intersection there
was a man standing there saying will
someone help me cross will someone help
me cross and there were all these people
that kept passing by him and passing by
him I said I'll help you cross so he
told me he was going to my school and he
was going to sell candy there that's how
he made his living so I helped him cross
the street to get there we became good
friends his name was mr. Butler that
moment reminded me of my mother bringing
her out of laughs out of pain and to
laughter to help her cross my first ten
movies were all about her subconsciously
wanting her to know that she was worthy
wanting black women to know you're
worthy you're special you're powerful
you're amazing
all of that was about helping across
when I started hiring people like taraji
and viola davis and idris elba they
couldn't get jobs in this town but here
God blessed me to be in a position to be
able to hire them I was trying to help
somebody cross you know building my
studio I built it in a neighborhood that
is one of the poorest black
neighborhoods in Atlanta so the young
black kids could see that a black man
did that and they can do it too I was
trying to help somebody
what a [ __ ] great example this
[ __ ] is right what a great a
Confederate Army Basin I want you to
hear this which meant that there was
Confederate soldiers on that base be
nodding and planning on how to keep 3.9
million Negroes enslaved now that land
is owned by one Negro oh [ __ ] bro damn
god damn holy [ __ ] that's a that's an
unbelievable speech that's it they just
thank you and Wow good right Wow man Wow
that's [ __ ] incredible
what an amazing Fox what that's that's a
guy who it's not about reparations not
about government anything that guy's
like that guy did it on his own or he
did it with the help of his mother and
everything else but what a badass
whatever what an inspirational what if I
gotta like his movies or any stuff but I
I respect him I appreciate him like I
don't like his uh my god what watches
movies really like I just don't like any
of them but I don't hate on it it's just
not my thing but I respect the [ __ ] out
of him
I just talents of what he does course
you do you know it's funny like yeah
like stuff whatever India what is the
day uh with the hiring of a black matte
black like that's no I'll see the way I
look at it some people like that so so
if you studied the history of this
country which I have done as you know
there is no doubt that there was such a
constant like onslaught on African
Americans it's so hard to be black just
in stuff for a thousand reasons Tilly's
but but again what happens is it's true
it's true that there is that legacy of
racism segregation and Jim Crow promise
when you said to me I
know what to do with that he did like in
a way this is gonna sound I'll take some
[ __ ] for this but in a way at the end of
the day nobody cares about you but you
like at the end of the other even if
they do there's a limit to what those
people can do for you there really is no
matter how much you and I give a [ __ ]
well I think emotionally right about
that like I want I want I truly want
people everywhere to be ok but I don't a
lot of times I don't know what to do and
at the end of the day the only person
that gets you out of your [ __ ]
situation I'm sorry but it might just be
only you it doesn't mean you don't have
help it doesn't mean you don't have
support doesn't mean only support but at
the end of the day you have to look to
yourself and maybe those closest to you
but it's you that gets you out of it
it's and I don't know if there's an
exception I really don't you know it's
it's and that that [ __ ] however
he did it he did it that's incredible
and it is harder it is harder when
you're a black kid growing up with a
single mom it [ __ ] is and maybe it's
almost impossible you know but goddamn
that's that's F we have a tough what a
simple strong speech the bridge great
right hmm cuz you know for me I'm not
comparing myself in any way because I
grew up overseas no and so when I when I
was in Saudi Arabia everybody would come
to work there from from Malaysia India
Africa the Philippines builting I yeah
and they would all sit around the
kitchen and to my mother's credit they
would all speak English cuz that was the
language so for two years I would sit in
that kitchen and my mother would let me
skip my homework and listen to them talk
and that's why when you always say you
always amazed it well I know where
people are from I do that's what it is
that was surrounded by so many different
colors yeah and then it becomes
impossible to not look at those people
who are Arabic or where and not
empathize with the fact that they're
exactly like you are you know I'd love
if you're like and then I saw a poor man
on the street and and he was selling
candy I decided to take two of them
cross the street push him in traffic and
I took his candy yeah just one up Tyler
Perry yeah now what else you got yeah no
you can't one up that story okay great
look I'm
she's done all right I'm sure you've
seen this already but Lavar ball is on
first take and he just made a quick
comment Somali kerim is a girl that also
hosts a show
I know Molly will so she said like okay
let's switch gears to do this and then
he just said oh I'd switch gears with
you anytime just kind of like us just a
passing remark or or everyone's a cow
dare you such a sexist and now yes Ben's
like we'll never have them on yeah our
platforms again I don't think it's that
big of a deal I'm gonna hero but I don't
really like why I think Liza balls a
great dad what he did with those kids is
amazing but this is a stretch man and
Molly's a friend of mine hmm go ahead go
ahead
can I switch gears with you because I
have a question
Sienna Smith gives oh Lord
so that's pretty much it that's all he
said I mean he's just being [ __ ]
quippy give me a yes what scared me
anytime and she can because she's hot as
[ __ ] so I mean she married him Jalen
Rose yeah so she made some sort of
statement Oh panicked by the [ __ ] was so
panicked she actually was cool with how
everything was that she's cool that uh
his can sort of cool dr. up but she was
said it was good to go but if she also
said later like it would be her husband
Jalen Rose would probably appreciate if
levar would apologize so and then it
becomes bigger than than it should all
right
I don't think you know what I don't
think knowledge that bit thinks it's
that big of a deal yeah I think it's
everyone else like oh we better do
something but also to have him banned
from ESPN's outrageous like like shut up
so he said the same thing did not nuts
it's the same thing when he says
something about switching gears and he
was like doing a gear shift motion with
Molly this is in 2017 can we switch
gears here all right so after this year
the Lakers
when they did it back to back in the end
it looks more like she's just saying
something like just to give on to the
next thing time you want I mean like I
don't think it's like I'm talking about
my dick I think you're just like yeah
you're a very attractive yeah human
being like that you do what do you want
give me your steering the show
she's awesome that's right here's the
show compliments exactly hell yeah you
can switch gears inside with me and I'm
sure the fireballs I go [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's pretty much what he said
okay yeah I think most and even if you
don't like the levar ball I think most
we were like ya know what the [ __ ] word
document it's just the politically
correct insanity that we're just it's
just such a ok but they won didn't they
well the left the left east though seems
to be running every few [ __ ] who cry
and then the s-pen hobby could she run
everything Google [ __ ] you and this one
here so you remember this teacher right
that had sex was so yacht that's why
this it's so funny when Barstow writes
this article
Jerry Thornton she's so hot one of the
greatest all-time mouth scandal teachers
she she of all the teeth she's she's the
hottest thing like she she is a kid she
was banging 13 well what is that about
that's such an interesting she's so good
looking but their faces she's well she
pled guilty okay um and grade though
like I've seen everything from she could
be sentenced up to 12 to 26 years with
the plea deal Wow alright and I don't
know if you guys ever saw this but you
can hear one of the kids
you'll hear a kid that took the tests
are set a testimony about her because he
it was his granny she's tiny and she's
very attractive 28 year old Brittany
Zamora is a cutie coached they would
like kind of oh that this girl is also
part of the school but she seems kind of
like a hater
the fat girl yeah of course she's a
hater this this depresses me she coached
they would like kind of hang on her
shoulder and hang on her back with their
arm around her she wouldn't let say oh
you know that's not appropriate she just
would kind of go with the flow and
cashews [ __ ] important this listen to
this student this gives you a good
reference intimate inside her car
when you hear that voice young right
when you hear the kid's voice you're
like this do so you wanted 12 it sound
there comes a couple things about this
you have to know you're gonna get caught
so what's going on you're clearly crazy
there's something crazy something cause
you go on
young cuff well I think it's cool us cuz
we're all older and could handle it but
I I know if I was 12 I would have been
free my child is gonna be 12 your
daughter yeah I mean that's very young
believe me see I it makes my - odd red
mad when it's a girl but if it's a boy
I'm like yeah I know that's she's that
hot
it still is called our double standard
disturbs the child you know can't be
good what also freaked out because I
think also I was talking about the
difference between penetration and
penetrating yeah it's it when you would
you're right Jim when you play a voice
like this sick it's not good no it
changes stuff is something wrong yeah
for sure we should probably figure it's
probably for fun we should probably go
talk to maybe sup like little boy you do
maybe bail her out so a little boys I
mean you doing maybe bail it out before
I just [ __ ] burn she's not getting
out is she about 12 to 27 years 26 years
that's excessive that seems really least
if it was a [ __ ] on the teacher was
a dying it's excessively different too
much I don't know what do you think yet
what's your take you're a woman god I
feel like she might have been abused
herself that's kind of the only thing I
can think of if he was a little older
like maybe 16 17 I can kind of see that
there was a teacher ah that used to
teach at my high school who was in a
similar situation
she moved schools and enough [ __ ] on
the students and went to prison she was
alright she was she was definitely one
of the prettier teachers was still like
okay yeah yeah I feel like she's ashamed
it's positive since I had a philia or
she could've been left for winning too
sometimes yes
a lot of times especially the serial
killers sometimes when they're molested
at that age they're stuck in that age
and that's what their tracks are you
that's right so she could read molested
at 12 or 13 yeah now she's just doing my
dad that's a really good morning so long
she's gonna have a terrible time in
prison yeah I think so should be
somebody's girlfriend that pretty mouth
I mean a bunch of women who hear about
her sexually abusing a 13 year old
there's little how many mothers do you
think are in their grandmothers aunts
and you know how cruel some women can be
seeming like hands made tail when they
beat the [ __ ] of that guy
yeah maybe you just kill yourself in
this situation I don't know no take it
easy we'll figure it out wait seven
years that's what I was kind of like
this is yet to come custody which means
you're in solitary commitment give an
hour a day to walk the yard bowl of
chili if you're lucky bowl of chili
that's awful this here this doctor well
this is a woman this woman is a doctor
but she gave up her doctor Korea to
become a model you're damn right I did
rice that's what's the problem here but
where she's from Mayan Mar Burma yeah
they don't like their women to show
these this type of addressing and
clothing so they took away her medical
license even though she did kind of
leave medical the medical field to
become model they still took it away but
she feels like obviously she worked to
earn that thing she can't take it away
do they still validate it I'll give all
understand her refugee status it's mono
she didn't work on me if she's gorgeous
look at her dude let her do your eyes
you know what I knew I needed lid talk
we'll fly her over Friday cutified I hit
my wife with that I'd end some other
people about to it it's not gonna kill
you know yet that is of a hound dog a
little bit I'm gonna be good looking
though dude have her do it
all right I pair then take your teasing
ball dart god bless her well not anymore
not anymore that's just a hot Instagram
my vets attend your vet to change how
you said that she's a 10 dude let me
borrow one your dog
from model let me borrow when your dog
she came in I was like I was like what
are we talking about here look at the
hips on her I'm a huge fan of hers and
that's all natural that's not [ __ ]
photoshopped I'm a fan no that's called
an hourglass figure
yeah she's delicious yeah yeah Marv I
had a little bit of a fling with a
Burmese girl mm-hmm in college my
freshman year and she was outstanding
[ __ ] outstanding real [ __ ] she was a
naughty girl just not a girl they
usually are and you know I do that do I
know the truth I might hear the story
what is a man she was uh tiny she was
tiny and tomorrow's like geez my my dick
is you know and you know I do I do
fairly well down there as you know yes
not bad
she hit me with all she goes what balls
and dick no I got dick more balls though
but I got a dick on me yeah but if
there's like you listen yeah if you're
on the witness stand and kids are dumb
enough identified you dick I kick your
Michael Jackson it's a huge balls right
and then I bet that's not true and then
you'd be like bummed out and then foo
boom do you have a gold ring attained
balls well I got me got a good-sized
dick but the outliers are nuts but she
grabbed my dick when it was Tana
oh yeah and she was so cute and small oh
wow I know did you say small I've never
had I was like that's not true you're
tiny she goes oh my other boyfriend my
boyfriend was had the biggest taken
where I was like what how big was it
because is he black uh I don't know I
didn't ask well I didn't ask how old
were yet to think I was uh I was 11
years old and I remember now I was a 18
I was 18 maybe my dong grew I guess you
dick I wanted you to get the yeah ding
supposed to get as smaller as you get
older what ya inverts like a turtle
something like that unless you put it to
use the way I do huh you know because I
I'm done growing I'm not gonna get
taller does your dick the same way like
out what age is a stop girl who knows
and here's keep
I'd say once she hit puberty it's over
that thing doesn't grow anymore
look at how Google the answers all that
question 18:19 your penis isn't likely
to grow much longer or thicker thicker
so you're stuck with what you got at 19
bro I I don't know I think I had a
growth spurt but not your boy your balls
balls in the wall grew and then I think
no one like in gym class as soon as i
carrying all the balls it's like this
big bad gravity working a bag yeah yeah
it's not a bad problem to have dude I
was loved because I was looking at
trying to look up the Internet
Luke Rockhold was at my house to see
trying looked up the Internet yeah Luke
Rockhold is like drinking coffee and I'm
and I leaned down a look at the Internet
to get it for him it's a code and as I'm
Lina I'm naked and and he takes a
[ __ ] picture like an [ __ ] with
balls of me squatter you yeah you just
see my balls it's just like I was like
you're such a dick just my my heavy sack
yeah it looks horrible
yeah looks like I was pulling it wasn't
me mr. sack it was just a card angry
dark sack yeah they get dollar pins well
then you are route yeah what are you men
thanks buddy that it's in just one one
more good news is high art well I know
you do a podcast we should I listen to
it when women ask me I literally like
sometimes I get a woman is like 40 and I
go don't let you I don't listen to it
real like oh no no host is Holly yeah
yeah no it's like they're trying to go
into a room where there's an orgy no no
I'm telling you it was some dude I'm
like a god if he's a cop or he's like I
got like a couple listen you'll love it
little yeah alright Canada banned
dolphins and whales in captivity but the
ones that are already in captivity will
be in captivity you can't really so
stink a street to the ocean yeah don't
don't release him in the streets they
can't do it dude look at that
that agent that's it we did it dude
get it again buddy what's his episode
35,000 I'm in Brea this weekend you want
to do can be a little spot on wedding
buddy are you going to weddings what
Joseph sir
[ __ ] that's right Alvin Chicago yeah
[ __ ] I know I wish I could go I know I
know it's gonna start fun I love those
guys yes be there hey my special
complicated a I wasn't doing my oh no no
I wasn't going go ahead no go ahead to
Trump go buddy my special complicated is
streaming on Amazon so you can download
it it's been doing it really well so
Brendan you're gonna be in Brad this
weekend I am that's what I was saying
before you interrupt 7 28 29 yep
Thursday Friday Saturday and anyway on
the Ohio yep I can do it buddy
Cincinnati Ohio I'm there Joe that's not
too July July 12th through the 13th I'm
in Indy where you were earlier right I'm
an Indy and the Nashville just want sale
as well get your takes now but Brea this
week Thursday Friday Saturday I'm not in
Spokane I'm not in Spokane until the
11th and 12th in July 18th of July San
Francisco Cobb's
July 19 and 20 get your frickin tickets
Friday and Saturday Cincinnati you know
that's it that's it for now oh yeah
shoot good for you t pack a calm Bray LC
this week
this fine kid we're out